If you want to about what's going on, I
will literally just take all the
screenshots of all the messages that I
have between Yi and Brett. I'll remove
your guys' personal identifying
information and I'll release it on
Twitter. It is not a crazy stance to say
that engaging in this kind of reckless
behavior while under civil lawsuit for
other reckless behavior is patently
insane and I will not be gaslit by moral
cowards into other perspectives.
Okay, so what happened is Connor and
Desi had their crash out. Connor said,
"You're age playing with a groper's
wife." And they had this whole fight and
all this, right? Connor, you come to
find out that the guy, the devil guy,
the thing he told Connor was that this
woman, his his wife, his ex-wife,
whatever, was doing some sort of age
play where they she involved the right.
They were stepparents like doing
something to the
Connor asked the wife about it and the
wife said, "No, the husband's just
husband's just making it up cuz he like
wants to win in a breakup or he's mad
and all of this and he's making it up."
So Connor went on his merry way like
told Destiny, "You shouldn't engage with
these kinds of people anymore. They
obviously have some problems and it's
really bad, right?" It seems like the
allegation has come out that now Destiny
got pictures of this guy's too, which is
crazy. Back in I assume November before
Come to like this month, Connor realizes
that Destiny is still texting this
woman, the woman who he thought was just
doing age play with him, some sort of
babysitter, right? And then Connor finds
out that this woman wrote into Mr. Girl
and discussed like explicitly not not
just age play, not just babysitter
stuff, but fantasizing about being the
steparents of each other's and involving
the in the role play. Okay. And that
changed Connor<unk>'s mind basically
immediately once he found out that that
was the allegation, that the allegation
was true and that Destiny had continued
to engage with this woman after Connor
had called him out for it. And so that's
like the quick rundown of why Connor was
so upset and why he felt the need to go
public with a bunch of this stuff. So,
you find out that uh your friend
who is being sued for a substantial
amount of money, who's lost $800,000 in
his lawsuit, is doing age play with a
BPD discord girl, and you tell him that
he's a and he's ruining his life.
>> I like it's unfortunate that Connor
picked this up from Destiny's community.
I just like it is stigmatization that
doesn't need to be done. And then
I find out on Friday, Saturday, I think
that he is still
the BPD egirl.
And uh within the past 72 hours, I have
found evidence that they did more than
babysitter roleplay.
And you think I'm the one who needs to
chill the out? How about you go tell
your internet dad to stop
>> boysitter role play
>> uh within the past 72 hours I have found
evidence that they did more than
babysitter roleplay
and you think I'm the one who needs to
chill the out
>> how about you go tell your internet dad
to stop roleplaying
scenarios.
How about that?
Oh, Jesus Christ.
What the
What is Connor? WHAT HAS CONOR GOT? WHAT
HAS CONOR GOT? Oh my god.
>> Don't Don't tell me it's normal. Don't
tell me off the scenarios is normal.
Don't tell me that. It's not normal.
It's freak. Steven's destroying himself
and I'm not interested in being a part
of his self-destruction.
>> So, if it wasn't the merits, it's the
approach.
>> Well, you could say that, but like you
said it in public and that's wrong.
Well, the pro the problem there is it
sounds like he said it in private and
the private criticism just didn't take.
Private criticism was not considered or
cared about. That's what it sounds like
to me. Holy
>> not doing this because of you. I'm doing
this in spite of you. Steven and I hung
out several times throughout 2025. Then
in November of 2025, I was contacted by
a man on Twitter. This gentleman says,
"I am a traditional Catholic. I am
married. My wife has destroyed our
family for destiny and no one's doing
anything about it." So I go, "Hen,
but I'm not the kind of guy who ignores
a problem. So let me go ahead and check
this out." And I talked to this
gentleman whose current profile on
Discord is called Devil. And Devil says,
"My wife and I are military veterans and
she has been in a communication
relationship with Destiny since February
of 2025."
And the reason why this is important to
me is because
>> it's very likely like some kind of
stress induced thing, right? After the
lawsuit,
>> Steven made the argument, as silly as it
was, that he had substantially reduced
his gooning and that he was not engaging
in reckless sex behavior the way that he
was.
>> Now, what the husband further said is
that they engaged in stepparent
roleplay, that they sent pictures of the
family, specific details unknown, that
he was deeply, deeply, deeply upset by
this, that he wanted vengeance against
Steven. And while the specifics may be
unclear in these series of messages as
to whether or not he wanted to commit
homicide against Steven, he's welcome to
release the logs and show whether
>> the vance didn't work. The vivance was
supposed to fix all this. THE VANCE
DIDN'T WORK.
>> NOT he ever expressed a homicidal desire
for Steven. I have logs of the wife
saying that her husband told her
repeatedly that he desired that Steven
were killed.
So when Destiny heard that Connor was
going to release this, by the way, he
did say some stuff over in his chat. I'm
just going to read that real quick.
Suji, I don't want to litigate my sex
DMs with it's insanely cringe. But
literally, anytime edge play has come up
in any of these combos, it is like I had
a hot babysitter. It's cringe how
fixated they are. Even if it went
further, it's literally just Oh, even if
it went further.
Uh, even if it went further, I I feel
like Connor is definitely hinting that
it went further. And so, it's weird that
he's saying this right here. Okay, let's
keep watching. So he says, "Okay, well,
oh," then he shared his text message
logs with me. Now, in the text message
logs, what I remember is that he was
accusing this person, his wife, of
engaging in steparent roleplay, of
involving pictures of their engaging in
lurid Aphib, Felic, depending on your
definition, roleplay, and how that was
repulsive and disgusting and he hated
her and hated Steven for doing this and
destroying his family. Dude, that's
that's uh that's pretty this is uh
pretty bad, man. Is that he was accusing
this person, his wife, of engaging in
steparent roleplay, of involving
pictures of their of engaging in lurid
roleplay and how that was repulsive and
disgusting and he hated her and hated
Steven for doing this and destroying his
family.
He says, "Well, she's actually a fan of
yours, so why don't you call her?"
>> What does that entail? I do. I have to
describe it. I don't feel like I have to
describe it. I feel like it's described
fairly well right there. And talk to her
about it and see what kind of evidence
or narrative she gives you. So, I do.
And what she says is, "No, that didn't
happen. My husband is exaggerating.
The family pictures had nothing to do
with the situations. And we engaged in
like some babysitter roleplay or
whatever, but it's not as bad as the
husband is making up, you know, she was
the initiator. She was the person who
pursued the relationship. And even
Steven said, "Hey, we should cut this
off." Like, let's not do this. You're
married. So, this is in November of 2025
is what Conor's saying. Okay. Your
husband is pissed off. You know, let
let's not do this. Okay.
So, to wick,
to hush, to people, my Twitter might
have gotten hacked, by the way. And so,
if my Twitter profile is texting
anything crazy right now, just know that
I've been hacked since probably 8 a.m.
this morning. So, I'm paying a price for
telling the truth, the whole truth, and
nothing but the truth. So, help me God,
as I've seen it, as I remember it.
>> I suspect snarkers are to blame. I
suspect Starkers are to blame right now.
>> So, I decide, hey, I gave him a shot
across the bow. I can't tell who's
telling the truth. I don't know if
Steven is being a, but Steven's a weird
guy, so whatever, or if it's worse. So,
I'm going to put this in. I'm going to
give Stephen a shot across the bow. I'm
going to ask the husband what he wants
to do, and I'm going to see if this
blows up or blow sideways or whatever,
but I don't have enough evidence to go
forward. Which brings us to the snarker
war. So, so once again, I want to
emphasize, I've heard Hutch saying this
should have been done in private. It was
done in private in November of 2025. I
heard Wix say that this should have been
done in private. It was done in private
in November of 2025. You know, Lauren
wanted to get back with you. Really?
>> Yes. She loves you. She wants the best
for you. She thinks that underneath all
the sludge and of your up little life,
there is something redeeming about you.
And I agree with her. BUT YOU ARE SUCH a
that it is impossible to be your friend.
It's impossible to be your partner. It
is impossible to tell you that you're
wrong. It's impossible for you to take a
L.
So take a L and take a goddamn lap.
>> I would just take a break. I would just
take a break from the internet for like
doesn't need to be a long break. I would
I if if I was Connor, I would take a
break. I I think it's time to log off
for a little bit. Literally don't even
look at the internet for like a week.
Why was this conversation had in public?
This is crazy. Why would this
conversation be had on a live stream?
>> Counterpoint should not have done what
he did. um going out in public and
basically putting other people's
business on blast like that was very
inappropriate. Very inappropriate.
And that's even dis that that's even
disassociating it from it from like the
streamer drama, the the friendship
dynamics there, right? You're you're
turning other people's business into
like a a weapon, man, into a bullet.
Okay, this was private. Steven did not
listen to me.
>> So, what's got to be frustrating here is
you know that these allegations are out
there. You know how crazy the
allegations are and it's not like
it it's not like he went, "Okay, well, I
should back off of this entirely." For
some reason, he keeps engaging with the
woman, right? Connor realizes they're
still talking as of like last week or
two weeks ago or something.
So, after these allegations, already as
like damning and gross as they are, had
come out, Destiny continued to interact
with the same person to me. He did not
consider me. He did not consider Kyla.
He did not consider Dan Saltman. He did
not consider Mr. Mutton. He did not
consider any of his future co-workers.
He did not consider America. He did not
consider CNN. He didn't consider a
single person when he engaged in this
behavior. And trust me, it gets a little
bit worse. So anyways, the snarker war.
I think that when Hutch and Wick are
confused about what Steven indiscretions
have to do with Steven's snarker anti
snarker campaign, I think they are
either being thoughtless or obtuse.
pretty clearly if you listen to any of
the snarkers, one of their primary
criticisms of Steven is the way that he
conducts his personal affairs. Whether
that's in reference to Sherry, whether
that's in reference to Anavoir, whether
that's in reference to Molina, whether
or not that's in reference to Lauren
Southern, whether or not that's in
reference to Pixie or Rose, it's quite
clear that Steven's personal conduct is
what is he he is most often criticized
for by the people who hate him. And not
only that, this conduct is not private.
It is not. We found out about Molina and
Lauren Southern and Rose because Steven
sent his not only homemade to Rose.
Dude, I I should say just in terms of it
not being private. There is another
thing here where
if if Destiny had a need for this,
right? Like I have a different thing
where I'm like, if I don't hear about
it, I don't care. Like just keep it
private, right? If it was just malicious
people leaking this stuff, I would maybe
understand. But it sounds like Destiny
intentionally engages in this sort of
stuff with people who are not stable,
right? Like he found somebody who is not
stable to engage in this stuff with and
and that risks it becoming public.
And realistically, I
that risks it becoming public, okay?
Which is harmful in and of itself. So on
Saturday, might have even been Friday
night, I get a message from Britney.
Britney contacts me. She says, "Oh, it's
crazy. I'm so sorry that you and Steven
are breaking up. Steven and I are still
talking." So, I want you to understand
this. Steven text messaged a woman, did
age play scenarios with her, got a shot
across the bow. Hey, this is up in
and he kept doing it.
Not only that,
this is going to be a tough one. Give me
a second. Not only that, but her and her
husband are broken up obviously, but
Steven thought it was prudent to receive
of the husband and this wife.
I want you to understand that.
>> Wait, what? Britt vacasillates between
endless adoration and love for Steven.
She truly loves him on a fundamental
level. I guess that's why everybody has
been saying over and over again that
both of them were involved in this thing
which is incredibly disturbing. That
didn't come after the thing with the
right. There's no way that there's no
way.
>> She thinks he's the best thing since
sliced bread. When Steven is not around
and is not communicating with her, she
gets
because she's mentally unwell.
Her husband has blamed Steven for the
implosion of his family.
Steven received a video of these two
mentally unstable, homicidal, and
military veterans having sex for his
personal enjoyment. That is something
that I was told on Saturday. And by the
way, that was confirmed by both parties.
That was confirmed by Brit and that was
confirmed by Devil.
So you can imagine
>> I'm I'm I'm like this is
I actually think if this guy sincerely
thought there was like the were involved
in some way and then they continued in
this the husband. I mean, I don't know
that you should have your man I I'm just
going to keep watching. I'm taking in
the information.
>> Frustration, rage,
>> taking in information that my friend
>> who is $800,000
down because he was imprudent
is still being imprudent in a way that
could get him killed and in a way that
could result in a woman's.
I am obviously angry about this fact.
It gets worse.
The snarkers have not corrupted my mind.
They have not minded me. They have not
manipulated me into my position. If you
take a look at my previous content, I
have been quite clearly critical about
Steven's misadventures. And when I
thought he was doing better, I was
praising him. And when I thought he was
up, I was criticizing him. So to
>> so we can call him a PDF now, right? Um
I mean you guys could call it whatever
you want. I
>> I'm just taking information that Jtock
Queen or Doobie talked to me for 2 weeks
and that somehow changed everything. It
did not. You were just not paying
attention to what I was saying
previously. The snarkers have given me
one thing
and one thing alone. I have verified
that this is Brit through information
that I have saved.
She wrote in to Mr. Girl's call-in show
via email to discuss her relationship
with Steven.
>> Dude, Mr. Girls involved. This is
confirmed. I cannot be sued for this
because I have the evidence that backs
up the truth of this scenario.
Let's listen. This year, I was involved
in an online affair with a guy for
almost a year. My husband wouldn't
engage with any of the weird
trauma-induced kink stuff that I was
curious about. And so, I was compelled
to impulsively and regrettably
regretfully engage with this guy online
and some pretty intense and taboo age
play scenarios, including fantasizing
about being stepparents to each other's.
And obviously, it went way too far. But
so, like that totally undercuts under it
totally undermines the wife saying, "No,
no, no. This didn't happen. No, no, no.
My husband's just overexaggerating.
Now, I've looked at this link. Somebody
sent me this link cuz they're ahead on
the stream. This is in January. So, this
is after she sent this after the
November 2025 leaks.
She sent this after. So, she was already
confronted and she'd already told Connor
that her husband wasn't that her husband
was making this up. And then she sent
this email to Max
>> about stuff that I was curious about.
And so I was compelled to impulsively
and regrettably regretfully engage with
this guy online in some pretty intense
and taboo age play scenarios including
fantasizing about being stepparents to
each other's and obviously it went way
too far but felt really intensely good
in the moment. But afterward I felt sick
and cried all night because it obviously
felt really bad too. How do you know if
the other person also feels the same way
or if they would actually do it? My
understanding is the best predictors are
drug use and low empathy. Uh, and even
worse, what if you felt like you love
them so much that you wouldn't care if
they did and you get off on what you
potentially be willing to allow them to
get away with? What if the idea is kind
of enticing to you in a way even if you
deny it or try to lie to yourself about
it? Even if you'd never act out on
something like that yourself, lucky for
me, it's over. Now, if you're saying
that you doubt your willingness to hold
boundaries in real life, then that is a
danger. Yes,
>> dude.
>> Back in November,
I had two conflicting stories.
Devil told me that this was the scenario
that there was stepparent roleplay
involving
Britney said no. It was babysitter.
Devil's exaggerating.
This
>> got the message. Conor's getting his
phone blown up. Oh no.
>> Is an email
confirmed to be Brit
sent to Mr. Girl. So, if I had to
prescribe for Steven trying not to hate
him, then I would say, this is my
unsolicited advice.
Destiny should balance his spicy public
takes to be spicy enough to get
attention, but not so violent
criticizable that people want to murder
him. He cannot in good faith and good
conscience blame the doxing sw and
harassment and attempted homicides
solely on the stochcastic permission
structure created by his snarkers.
He cannot do that while he is a woman
who is presently married who was hanging
out in a traditional Catholic group chat
that was plotting or at least joking and
stochcastically trying to work each
other up to his homicide. That is a lie.
Destiny should evidence his claims that
Snark is responsible for his swatting,
doxing, and digital harassment beyond
criticism.
Destiny should focus on political
commentary and community development in
order to get another college
event/canvasing operation going for both
of the midterms in 2028 if he wasn't a
instead he's on the internet using a
champion to defend his honor against
criticizing his personal life.
Meanwhile, he engages in even dumber
reprehensible actions.
God damn.
>> And his cult of
say that I'm pocket watching because I'm
worried about him losing $800,000 in
legal expenses.
>> They actually say you're watching
mostly, Connor. They say that I'm
watching because I'm criticizing him for
engaging in stepdad roleplay with a
random insane woman on the internet
while he's being sued for misconduct.
So, no offense to the people in my chat
who are likely spuring the out who I
cannot presently see, but if you say
pocket watching or if you say
watching,
you're a piece of [__] and you would let
Steven
if it amused you for 2 seconds on the
internet.
>> Jesus, be in the back. My stance is that
it is not neutral or positive to engage
in a theophelic or roleplay.
I think it's bad.
If you think it's neutral or good and
you are a current member of my
community, I ask one of two things from
you. You either keep that opinion. Any
clarification on the couple of
steparents situation? It sounds like
Desi was engaging as a steparent in some
fantasy roleplay that made this woman
uncomfortable. Now, why would you call
it stepparent roleplay? That went way
too far and made you feel disgusted. If
being a steparent didn't matter, if it
was just the two of you operating,
right?
Or you leave my community. And if let's
say that all of my oilers, all of my
chippers, all of my community support
come from people who think this is not a
big deal and who think that it is
perfectly sane and rational for Steven
to be
in homicidal people while currently
being sued for misconduct. I don't want
your money.
I would rather destroy my stream.
>> This is like one of his top guys. No
way. The scenarios didn't involve their
it involved scenarios of them being
stepparents
brother
meaning career brother
>> and I would rather go back to working
construction administration as a nobody
>> who participates in this space as a
hobby than continue to rely on your
viewership or financial support.
>> It's actually over. It's not over at
all. It's not over at all. This will
literally not affect Essie's like
primary support but from his audience.
One iota just so you know if you think
if you think anything said here would
affect any supporter of his whatsoever,
you are wrong. You are coping. This
doesn't affect him with his viewers one
tiny iota.
Not even a little bit. There is not a
single Destiny viewer who has any
problem with any of the things
described.
And if they did, they would no longer be
viewing.
>> How about you take this l we've been
secretly dating for 3 months. He was
lying when he said that I asked out
Lauren and got rejected. He was lying
when he has implied that what has
motivated me is jealousy out of his
relationship for Lauren Southern. He is
lying to you.
>> If you want to l me and Lauren have been
dating for like 3 months and we both
agreed not to tell you because you asked
her.
>> So I'm going to pause it right there
because he just lied. He just lied,
guys. He's not dating Lauren. He's not
dating Lauren. He just lied. He just
lied that he's still dating Lauren to
try and get one over on Connor in this
conversation, he literally immediately
after this, he goes into DGG chat and
admits. He says, "Guys, I'm sorry. I
misrepresented. Me and Lauren broke up
two weeks ago. She's been soed over by
every guy in her life.
No joke. That's what he goes to DG and
says immediately after, you know, he's
trembling, freaking the out because he
obviously actually does kind of care
about Lauren a little bit deep down and
he just literally he throws it away in
this moment to try and get the win for
his ego. Rather than engaging in a
healthy relationship with a woman he
loves, he would rather go do stepparent
age play with random women on Discord
and Tinder. He is a socially and human
being who has destroyed his personal and
professional life because he is so
dysfunctional and I am not going to be a
part of it. I'm not going to be silent
about it. It is not a crazy stance. It
might be a crazy stance in some online
communities, but it is not a crazy
stance to say that in a
roleplay is crazy. It is not a crazy
stance to say that engaging in this kind
of reckless behavior while under civil
lawsuit for other reckless behavior is
patently
insane and I will not be gaslit by moral
cowards into other perspectives
specifically. Thank you Hutch. Thank you
Wick. Why is this all in the open? I
don't know. Why the do I know about it?
Why is this HAPPENING IN PUBLIC? I KNOW.
I KNOW. ISN'T THAT A GREAT QUESTION TO
ASK? BUT YOU'RE ASKING THE WRONG PERSON.
>> If this is his private life and his
private life is private, why do I know
about it? Is it because he recklessly
engaged with mentally ill people who
contacted me and told me about it? Is
that why
>> the husband's about to call in? Got
husband in. Husband coming in hot. I've
asserted that Britt engaged based off of
your information, by the way, um that
Stephen and Brit engaged in age
roleplay, stepparent roleplay involving
your family back in the day, like
November and last year.
>> All right. In terms of stuff,
>> I mean, that's pretty much out there.
Everybody, you know, everybody's saying
that uh pretty much, but in terms of the
Mr. girl stuff if I can talk about
anything. I guess uh from what I
understand she played up a lot of that
because she was like watching Mr. Girl
at the time and blah blah blah and when
she wrote in she elaborated a bit is my
understanding and what she's telling me.
I don't have any direct knowledge of
that stuff. So
>> So uh what's the what what is your
understanding because obviously we had a
conversation in November.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think that you told me
>> something almost identical to what Brit
wrote into Mr. Girl.
>> So where was that coming from? He never
told me like the parts about him or her
being turned on by him actually doing
IRL. Like none of that was ever
mentioned. It was always just, hey, this
is a thing that happened one time. He
didn't really want to do it, but I kind
of wanted to do it and we both felt bad
about it and didn't do it anymore. That
was the story she gave me, but never
denied it happening, of course. But that
was like it wasn't this ongoing thing uh
supposedly from what I know. But like I
said, I'm just going off. I never saw
the logs between them. It was mostly
like on Discord, etc. or whatever her
stuff. So I'm 100% just going off what
she told me.
>> Yep. So, um, I'm gonna I'm gonna
disconnect this call and I'm gonna point
something out to chat. Okay. So,
Devil
wrote to me immediately.
>> Oh, he he's going to lean into the fact
that the husband just said that it
happened before.
>> I can call in,
>> but I'm going to downplay everything.
I'm actually even going to go ahead and
omit a detail so I can save Devil a
little bit of heartache. Here you go.
>> Yeah. I mean, I already said this that
the guy is going to like this is a
serious situation where where the health
and safety of his question, so obviously
he'd have to downplay it. And the guy
saying this is
Yeah. Okay. Well, Jesus. So, no offense,
you dumb,
but everybody's lying. So, once again,
this So, don't worry.
You want the evidence?
I got you. I got you, devil. If you want
to call back in, go ahead. But the only
thing that I want to hear from you is
what I heard from you in November.
So, if you want me to call you, I'll
call you. But I'm not I'm not doing this
self sweeping. So, if you need to self
sweep because this is serious, that's
fine. But I'm not helping you self
sweep. Hello.
>> I can hear you. Now, Devil, I'm going to
say this and I'm going to say this
exactly once. You and I spoke in
November. You made some extreme
allegations against Brit. I wasn't able
to make heads or tails. That Mr. Girl
email sounds identical to the messages
or excuse me to the allegations that you
were making in November. I have on my
screen right now. I can, but I'm going
to downplay everything. So, if you want
to talk to me about what really
happened, then I'll be happy to talk to
you. If you want to about what's going
on, I will literally just take all the
screenshots of all the messages that I
have between you, me, and Brett. I'll
remove your guys' personal identifying
information and I'll release it on
Twitter because that's what you wanted
to do in November.
>> By downplaying, I did not mean that I
was going to lie. simply meant that I'm
not going to go into all the details,
specific details that can get me and my
family personally [__] up. You know,
this thing to do. Now, I will talk to
you and I will tell you, like I said,
leave the logs if you want.
>> I mean, he's quite literally he's quite
literally saying that this happened
right now.
>> But I like I had no knowledge of some of
the things she said in that email. And
from what I understand, what she told
me,
>> then why did you tell me the exact same
thing that was in the email in November?
>> Oh, brother, this guy's not ready.
>> What did I tell you in the email? I
don't I have screenshots. I go pull it
up. I'll tell you exactly what you told
me because I still got screenshots. So,
you told me in November that Britt and
Destiny were role playing as parents in
reference to their own.
You also told me that they role played
as your
>> Okay, but specifically, like I said, in
terms of downplaying, I mean, I'm going
to give you I'm not going to try to like
>> Oh, dude. Oh,
>> or did that not happen?
>> That is what I was told. I have no
direct evidence of that. I do not know.
>> You don't have the videos or
screenshots, but Britney said that that
happened to you. I mean, Britney told
you the same thing, didn't she?
>> She did. Well, actually, hold on, hold
up, hold up. Britney downplayed it and
she said that they did babysitting
fantasies.
>> Well, that Hold up. To be clear, what
happened is you told me exactly what was
in the Mr. Girl email. Then Brit told me
that they just did babysitting
fantasies. I wasn't able to make heads
or tails of it. The only reason why I
was going public with this is because
Britt wrote Mr. Girl telling me what you
told me.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I I didn't know. Well,
I don't know everything she told you
either. I've never seen y'all's vlogs or
y'all's conversations, but I just know
what she told me. And she told me that
that happened once and never happened
again. And if downplaying is just
telling the truth about what she told
me. I mean, I don't think I said they
were doing it constantly either. And I
shouldn't have even gotten into all that
personally, but I was, you know,
crashing out at the time. Is what it is.
>> By the way, I told her skitso earlier.
She's not a skitso. She is, she does
have BPD, but she's not a skitso. Trying
to clear that up.
>> That's funny. Why adult?
>> She's still an adult. She can still do
what she wants. You know, it's it is
what it is.
>> Oh, because she had no affair with
Destiny. I mean, among all the others,
you know, pretty obvious.
>> Okay. Okay. Did Desi know you were
married?
>> Uh, I don't even know if that's public
knowledge or any of that. Is Is it? I
don't know. I mean, it I
know that was in contention.
>> Oh, we're caught up. We're caught.
>> It's not It's not in contention. The
reason Okay, let me tell you what I'm
trying to do, Devil. What I'm trying to
point Let me tell you the the picture
that I'm trying to paint.
>> The picture that I'm trying to paint is
you came to me in November and you said
>> that they role played as stepparents.
that Steven received pictures of your
that were not in a context, but she he
still knew what they looked like. They
role played stepmom, stepdad's fantasies
in which the were being.
And then they also role played as the
themselves engaging in an interest and
that was so disturbing to you
>> that you wished you could destroy the
online personal and professional
reputation of Destiny.
>> That's what you told me in November. So
is that accurate or not?
>> At the time I definitely did want to
destroy the online personal reputation
of Destiny. This is true. Yeah.
>> Okay. And was my description of what you
told me in November accurate or no?
>> Uh, I don't remember if I said exactly
like that. Like I said, I'd have to pull
it up. Uh, but it I mean, I was pissed.
I pretty much just told you generally
what she told me. Um, I who knows. Like
I said, I really need to go back and
look at it. It's been so long. I'm
trying to move past it, you know, trying
to get my own going on, you know, get my
own thing together. But in terms of I
mean I mean, like I said, you got the
locks. I don't even know why you need me
to be honest. that I don't really
personally want to.
>> So, so the thing that you wanted to the
thing that you wanted to clarify is that
you are uh you were not in a tele a
telegram group that was planning
Destiny's
>> I was not in a telegram group. There was
a conversation that happened and I
essentially said like like what you're
doing is insane. You got to chill. Blah
blah blah. Like you know you're going to
get way too many eyes on us. Shit's
going to hit the fan at some point. You
know
>> what what else do you want to clarify?
Uh,
I don't know, man. I just want everybody
to know that like, are me and Destiny
best friends? No. But I don't hate him
now. Like, he's a adult. She is, too. He
can dig his own grave, do what he wants
to, and she can, too. It's none of my
business anymore. I just wanted to kind
of move past this. I know there's a lot
of other people at risk, blah, blah,
blah. I've heard all the different
things, but I mean, this is destiny.
Like, what what are you going to do? A
BPD girl wants to reach out to him.
They're going to reach out to him. You
can't get him.
>> Wife, dude. I
just,
>> you know,
>> sick, man.
>> At this point, it's kind of my life even
more. Like, I was It's been six months
now, and I'm like kind of wanting to
just move past this.
>> DJ,
>> I understand that, but we're we're in
it, man. You involved me in November,
and Brit involved me last week, so we're
in it whether you like it or not. So,
did uh
>> I I legitimately feel like ill watching
this. Brit, did Brit convince you to
shoot homemade and then send it to
Stephen?
>> No. No, no, no, no. We're not gonna
We're not We're not gonna do that. We're
not gonna do that. We're not doing that,
Conor.
>> Okay.
>> All right. What else do you want to
clarify?
>> Like I said, I don't want to get into
like all the different It's complicated.
You know what I mean? And like as far as
I'm concerned, I have
>> I guess that's all I really need to
clarify. I don't know, man. It just
sucks. And I wish people would off and
just kind of let us live our lives at
this point.
>> Okay. Not in my [__] [__] I'll tell
you I'll tell you right now I would have
loved for all of us to have moved on and
lived our lives. But
>> what happened was Steven was making
claims that rant the snarkers but
>> Connor why were you mad at Destiny still
messaging Brit if she was single. Bruh
>> whatever they're responsible for the
doxing swatting and harassment and
threats to his life.
>> Oh these people are ill. These people
are ill, man. Like, these are the people
who've been defending him. I knew I said
that they it wouldn't make a dent, but
it's just gross to watch in real time.
>> I got you in November saying that you
wish you could destroy Steven's life and
alleging some pretty extreme things
about what he did with your wife.
>> And then I got Brit writing into Mr.
Girl identifying nearly identically
exactly what you described to me. Then I
have Brit contacting me on Friday
stating that not only did that telegram
exist, but then on top of that uh that
she is currently in communications with
Destiny right now. So for me, I know
this sucks. I know that I I do not I do
not dislike you at all, but what's
happening is because you're scared,
>> you're walking back that you told me
previously, and I'm not I'm just going
to release the logs.
>> I mean, that's that's that's that's
fine, man. You know, uh I I'll message
you later about some. But look, like at
the end of the day, these are two
adults. It happened one time according
to them. That's what she told me back
then, too. I got I got logs with her,
too, talking about it. And like she's
supposedly I mean, she's in therapy now,
man. Like, she's she's trying to get
herit together. And if she wants to
message Destiny from time to time, it's
not that deep, honestly. I feel like But
yeah, is it up? Yeah, it's up. Would I
do it? No. Is it DJ? I think so. But
it's nothing ever happened that was
technically illegal as up as it is. And
I'm trying to maintain peace and harmony
in my life as much as I can. And yeah,
sure. I don't really give a [__] who
wants to kill Destiny. I'm sure there's
like 20 communities out there that want
to kill Destiny. Wow. You know, like
what?
>> This guy's ex-wife. Ex-wife.
>> Is he's Destiny. He's Epson. What are
you going to do?
>> I just I should have said that. That's
[__] up. But yeah, at the end of the
day, I have no beef with Destiny. Uh I'm
sure a lot of people have valid reasons,
too. And I probably do, too. But I'm
willing to live and let go and move on.
He's using stalker terms
>> my life and I hope whatever snarker he's
gay fake internet he's involved with you
know I hope that works out for him.
>> Okay. Well then uh anything else you
want to clarify before I let you go?
>> Uh that uh nothing much. It was
interesting being you know uh bit
infamous for a minute. I hope it passes
over. Uh wouldn't recommend but uh
thanks for letting me call in and
clarify a few things.
>> All right. Good night, bud.
>> All right. Stay safe. Don't die. You
too.